you so i have to earn my value yeah so
i'm invaluable say that again that's
what that's what no i'm saying the more
you sleep with men the less value will
you become oh i thought you know okay
i'm not saying that i know i'm saying
that
i'm saying that i'm not i mean
the older you get the less valuable if
you're over the guy was it who was it
kevin smith 35 you're undateable it
doesn't mean you're it doesn't mean
you're not indictable no it's a low
value you're a low-value woman but it
doesn't mean you're undateable it means
that you're less valuable than you were
when you were like 10 15 years ago oh
you can't compete for the example
you can't compete for the same guy but
i'm saying men it's the opposite the
older people the same men was fighting
one in 15 years ago no no i'm the same
kind type of guy you're competing for
the same 20 percent of guy even though
you think it's a new guy guys guys
because because okay i'm 25 right i
could date a guy up to 45 i'd be fine
with it and so like even even now we're
competing for the same guy
and that's so that's what he's saying
yeah so you've got the advantage you're
25 i get it and
just to clarify i wasn't saying that
like you know women are less valuable
with age it's just that obviously it
becomes a bit harder for women because
of age in the dating market because
obviously there are certain trends right
men tend to prefer younger women there
are certain elements of being younger
that are advantageous in dating like
vitality and having a certain mindset
that men can find refreshing at times it
gets harder for women i think we all
understand that right but for men
you know what the older you get the
better you learn to engage with women
you're better you know you don't say the
goofy stuff you used to say when you
were like 20. no the younger women are
more susceptible to your to your
[ __ ] i was going to say i think as
you get older
you tend to not really you can't do the
[ __ ] you can and you can see it
coming like straight right but but this
is where you go back to it's the same
same prize lower value higher price yeah
and that's that's the biggest complaint
i hear from men with older women i'll
tell you a story actually this happened
to me a few weeks ago
there's two but i'll tell you this one
first so there was this girl i met in a
club she was great she was in a similar
scene as me
and she looked very good this night i'm
very direct with my interest i was like
damn you looking good whatever talking
all that crap
um
we we're having a chat on the side and
she's you know acting all coy and she's
like i don't i don't date in this scene
i was like all right all right so uh
like so you want me you know your kind
of dinner date kind of girl cool cool
cool
i found out that girl's been with almost
all of my boys
right so so for me for me she you know
she she kind of you didn't continue you
didn't take oh no i did i did i got a
number i never spoke to her again and
now she looks at me like i'm some kind
of alien every time she sees me it's
like
but that's that's the kind of story of
how it works sometimes does it make you
improve
absolutely because you knew that you was
a disadvantage when she told you that
right
yes i knew that there was something i
didn't understand and then when when my
boys told me like yeah like she's she's
been with their bear these man i said oh
okay i get it you just believed what
your friend said why would they lie
why wouldn't they lie do you not think
it's the same the other way around
though yeah so like if if i meet a guy
and i know that he's slept with everyone
in this community all of my friends like
do you really think i'm still gonna be
yeah
most women are still attracted to him i
mean look at drake women are stealing
his condoms that's because he's famous
and people have this ludicrous kind of
imagery of celebrities that's true
that's true but in in general women pick
men that other women want
because it's a sign it's a sign of
pre-selection and the reason and i can
give you an example women say men are
trash all the time and they lie and they
cheat well who are they lying and
cheating i think that comes down to
like going back to the age thing as well
though because maybe when you're younger
you think about that but when you get
past a certain point you're kind of
looking for more stability
and somebody you can trust yeah i think
that really yeah because but that's
that's what happens though women below
the age of like 27 tend to date the bad
boys but and then and then they get ran
through by the bad boys and then ask for
a nice guy to pick up the pieces yeah
like why why should i have to deal with
your your issues after you've just
you had the chance when you was 21 the
chance when you was 22 23 20. now i'm
gonna go club i wanna do this i want to
please babes i want to wire for you no
no no no i ain't got time for you
do you know on the count of three
everyone shout out their body count five
but do you get my point um
do you get my point if it's
no you're not ashamed of it because it's
five yeah if it was 55 you'd stay quiet
yeah yeah
no you would stay quiet yes
if i was 55 it wouldn't have it wouldn't
necessarily me staying quiet because we
know what the um
what it's like like it's not it's not a
bad thing necessarily for me to be
sleeping around can i just say something
that i am
myself obviously i've had long term
relationships so i'm fine but
what i will say is for the younger
generation
it's very difficult to have a low body
count now because and it's it's because
of older women not even
you lie to the younger women why are you
like no because you don't want them to
wait can i just say that
can i just let me just say something
like you're saying dating and we're
saying connections and we're giving out
all this there's so many people the
social media has ruined dating it's like
there's so much variety there's so much
what you should be expecting what you
shouldn't be expecting so
it's so fickle dating is so fickle now
how how are young girls expected to keep
their body count down
when but
there's there's no relationships now
like it's not like back in the day where
you had a long-term like relationship
mostly our age were the last of the
long-term relationships i'm not gonna
lie well men men have definitely dropped
their standards for what they used to
accept a girl used to be a host she
slept with more than two people now a
guy prays for five
i do listen and i've seen i've seen guys
i've seen a lot of hosts got wifed a lot
that's true
but they're also the first divorced
because i always say a woman sleeping
around it hurts herself more than anyone
else because it impacts her ability to
pair bond
so women have a hard time staying when
they've slept with too many people
statistically because yeah because women
that have slept with more than five men
yeah their their chance of a happy
marriage drops from at one eighty
percent after ten years they're going to
be in a happy marriage to 30 percent
after five partners after 10 years so i
can't sleep with any more guys or else
i'm going to drop in the possession
that is
but that's what i'm saying is like
there's reasons behind it
do you think do you think that's gonna
work
no more sex yeah dude like that's what i
mean when i say you making him wait and
you're making him wait
the guy just had it like that it's like
now i'm i'm on my i'm on my i'm just
gonna have to go back to someone i've
had sex with
yeah that's what i said that's why i
asked you should have married your
partner
oh come on man no no that's not i know
you explained it to me but that's why at
first i said you should have married
your partner if you married your partner
in year one
you would have divorced when your
problems happen but you would have been
married but what's that that's just no i
mean i don't listen i grew up here i
grew up let me let me give you this i
don't know if it's my cousin's fault i
blame her um i was a protestant in
scotland as protestant catholics my
cousin was a catholic as a protestant
she got to make a communion and i didn't
she religiously i stayed at her house
and most days when my mom was working
she used to dress me in a trouser suit
and she dressed up in her communion
dress and made us play weddings like in
the living in front of everyone and it
really daunted me that she always made
me be the guy like it hurt me a lot so i
just was like i hate weddings
i don't know if it's instilled i haven't
ever had the wish to be married i don't
dream of the white dress i don't at the
commitment that is for the government to
say you're married like i dream of real
love like that's all i've ever done but
marriage marriage is a business and i